learn stromer's my name is Josh
Sundquist I am a youtuber best-selling
author and a Paralympic ski racer I
first started ski racing when I was a
teenager I went to my first race
thinking I was like the best skier of
all time and it was gonna be amazing I
was like super excited about and I'm
sure that's kind of how you feel when
you start anything in life right like
maybe even when you started this class
and I went through the course and I
actually fell on like the third turn in
the course and that was really
disappointing and I was like I I
expected I was gonna ski really well and
and I fell and I think that is an
inevitable part of anything including
this course right you're really excited
at first and then like something happens
a problem right you fall you get
discouraged and it's in that moment I
think you have a choice about do you
want to quit like do you want to just be
like that it's not for me because I fell
or do you want to say no falling is just
part of the process it's just something
that happens on the way and if you wanna
cross the finish line
at the end of the race course says if
you want to finish the class you have to
get back up so I got back up and I fell
down again I got the guy before I
actually fell in five times in this race
course it was not very good as it turns
out but I kept getting back up and for
that reason I eventually crossed the
finish line and so what I want to say to
you is that when you fall when something
doesn't work out quite the way that you
wanted when you get discouraged that's
not a reason to quit that's just part of
the process and it's in those moments
that you have to look at the finish line
that you're trying to reach and say
alright I'm gonna get back up and I'm
gonna keep getting back up as many times
as it takes until I cross that finish
line so keep up the good work keep
getting back up and good luck in the
rest of your class